what i want to do first is just show you
what the angle bisector theorem is and
then we'll actually prove it for
ourselves so i just have an arbitrary tr
arbitrary triangle right over here
triangle abc what i'm going to do is i'm
going to draw an angle bisector for this
angle up here we could have done it with
any of the three angles but i'll just do
this one it'll make our proof a little
bit easier so i'm just going to bisect
this angle angle abc so let's just say
that that's the angle bisector of angle
abc and so this angle right over here is
equal to this angle right over here and
let me call this point down here let me
call it point d
the angle bisector theorem angle
bisector
bisector theorem
tells us that the ratio between the size
that aren't this bisector so when i put
this angle bisector here it created two
smaller triangles out of that larger one
the angle bisector theorem tells us the
ratios between the other sides that of
these two triangles that we've now
created are going to be the same so it
tells us that the ratio of a b
the ratio of a b
to a d
to ad is going to be equal to the ratio
of bc
the ratio of bc to you could say cd
to
cd so the ratio of
i'll color code it the ratio of that
which is this
to
this
to this
is going to be equal to the ratio of
this
which is that
to
this right over here to cd which is that
over here so it's kind of once you see
the ratio of that to that's going to be
the same as the ratio of that to that so
that's kind of a cool result but you
can't just accept it on on faith because
it's a cool result you want to prove it
to ourselves
and so you could imagine right over here
we have some ratios set up so we're
going to prove it using similar
triangles and unfortunate for us these
two triangles right here aren't
necessarily similar we can't really we
know that these two angles are congruent
to each other but we don't know whether
this angle is equal to that angle or
that we don't know we can't make any
statements like that so in order to
actually set up this type of a statement
we'll have to construct maybe another
triangle that will be similar to one of
these right over here and one way to do
it
one way to do it would be to draw
another line and this is a bit of this
proof wasn't obvious to me the first
time that i thought about it so don't
worry if it's not obvious to you is that
what happens is if we can continue this
bisector this angle bisector right over
here so let's just continue it it just
keeps going
on and on and on and let's also maybe we
can construct a similar triangle to this
triangle over here if we draw a line
that's parallel to a b down here so
let's try to do that so i'm just going
to say well you know you could always
find if c is not on a b you can always
find a point that goes through our line
that goes through c that is parallel to
a b so let's just by definition let's
just create another line right over here
and let's say and let's call this point
right over here f and let's just pick
pick this line in such a way that fc is
parallel to a b so this
is parallel to that right over there so
fc
fc is parallel to a b and we can just
construct it that way and now we have
some interesting things and we did it
that way so that we can make these two
triangles be similar to each other
so let's see that let's see what happens
so before we think about similarity
let's think about what some of the
angles or what we know about some of the
angles here
we know that we have alternate interior
angles so just think about these two
parallel lines so i could imagine a b
keep keeps going like that fc keeps
going like that
and line bd right here is a transversal
then whatever this angle is whatever
this angle is this angle is going to be
as well from alternate interior angles
which we've talked a lot about when we
first talked about angles with
transversals and all of that so these
two angles are going to be the same but
this angle and this angle are also going
to be the same because this angle and
that angle are the same this is a
bisector because this is a bisector we
know that angle abd is the same as angle
dbc so whatever this angle is that angle
is and so is this angle and that gives
us kind of some kind of an interesting
result because here we have a situation
we have a situation where if you look at
this larger triangle bfc
we have two base angles that are the
same which means this must be an
isosceles triangle so bc must be the
same as fc so bc
must be the same as fc so that was kind
of cool we just use the transversal and
the alternate interior angles to show
that these are isosceles and that bc and
fc are the same thing and that could be
useful because we know that we we want
to we we we have a feeling that this
this triangle and this triangle are
going to be similar we haven't proven it
yet but how will that help us get
something about bc up here but we just
show that bc and fc are the same thing
so this is going to be the same thing if
we want to prove it if we can prove that
fc the ratio of a b to a d is the same
thing as the ratio of fc to cd we're
going to be there because bc we just
showed is equal to
is equal to fc but let's not let's not
start with the theorem let's actually
get to the theorem so fc is parallel to
a b able to set up these isosceles tri
this i this one isosceles triangle so
these sides are congruent now let's look
at some of the other angles here and
make it make ourselves feel good about
it well we have this if we look at
triangle abd so this triangle right over
here in triangle fdc we already
established that they have one set of
angles that are the same and then they
also both
abd has this angle right over here which
is going to which is a vertical angle
with this one over here so they're
congruent and we know if two triangles
have two angles that are the same
actually the third one is going to be
the same as well or you could say by the
angle angle similarity postulate these
two triangles are similar so let me
write that down you want to make sure
you get the corresponding sides right
we now know by angle angle and i'm going
to start at the green angle that
triangle b and then the blue angle
b
d
a
is similar to triangle so once again
let's start let's start with the green
angle f then you go to the blue angle f
d c
f
d
c
and here we want to eventually get to
the angle bisector theorem so we want to
look at the ratio between a b and a d
a b and a d similar triangles either you
could find the ratio between
corresponding sides are going to be the
same one
similar triangles or you could find the
ratio between two sides of a similar
triangle and compare them to the ratio
of the same two corresponding sides on
the other similar triangle and they
should be the same so by similar
triangles we know that the ratio of a b
and this is this by the way was by
angle angle similarity want to write
that down
so now that we know they're similar we
know that the ratio of a b to a d we
know the ratio of a b
to a d is going to be equal to and we
could even look here for the
corresponding size the ratio of a b the
corresponding side is going to be c f is
going to equal
c f
over
a d a d is the same thing as c d over c
d
and so we know the ratio of a b to a d
is equal to c f over c d c f over c d
but we just proved to ourselves because
this is an isosceles triangle that c f
is the same thing as b c right over here
so c f is the same thing as b c and
we're done we've just proven a b over a
d is equal to b c over c d so there's
kind of two things we had to do here is
one construct this other triangle that
allowed us
assuming this was parallel
that gave us two things that gave us
another angle
to show that they're similar and also
allowed us to establish sorry i have a
some something stuck in my throat
just coughed off camera so um i i should
go get a drink of water after this
so we were able to using constructing
this triangle here we're able to both
show it similar and to construct this
larger isosceles triangle to show look
if we could find a ratio between two
sides of this triangle and this one then
that's going to be the ratio of the this
if we could find the ratio of this side
to this side is the same as ratio of
this side to this side that's analogous
to showing that the ratio of this side
to this side is the same as bc to cd and
we are done